Eastern areas of Ukraine are bracing for
what they fear will be a new Russian
offensive Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski warned that Russian troops are
carry are moving to carry out
large-scale military operations in the
east of the country Russian bombardments
struck various sites across Ukraine
through the weekend into nepro the
country's fourth largest city missiles
destroyed the local airport and wounded
several people
meanwhile investigators continue to
exhume bodies from Mass Graves around
the capital Kiev Ukraine authorities say
more than 1200 bodies have been found so
far following the withdrawal of Russian
forces from the areas
our correspondent Alexandra from Norman
is covering this story and joins us now
from Kia Alexander we keep hearing that
Russia is about to launch a major
offensive in the east and south of the
country how is Ukraine preparing for
this
Ukraine is strengthening its defenses in
the East and the south of the country
sending more troops there and a clear
anticipation of a major Russian
offensive there the authorities are also
urging civilians there to leave as long
as they can according to the general
staff of the Ukrainian armed forces the
Russian army is trying to break the
defenses of the strategically important
city of ezium and they are trying to
capture the city of mariopul that as you
know has been under siege for many weeks
now on the clear goal here seems to be
for the Russians to take control of the
donbass area of the donbass region
including Donetsk dedonetsk and luhanska
regions
Russian forces have left a trail of
Destruction Alexandra in areas that
they've withdrawn from in the north
north of Kiev uh you've been there
you've been traveling different to
different places there what have you
seen
we went for instance to the city of
China yesterday the city was under
Russian siege for many weeks at for some
period of time it was completely cut off
from the outside world the people there
told us they didn't have water no
electricity they suffered from Hunger
some went on for days without eating
anything many areas of the city are
completely destroyed schools a hospital
residential houses but judge for
yourself let's have a look at our report
from trinihif
the city of Journey here after weeks of
Siege and heavy shelling by Russian
forces we meet Svetlana and Valentino
sepienco in a local hospital they
survived but were both injured in an
airstrike that hit their house
it took less than a second
we just heard a whistle
I screamed get down and covered my son
foreign
Valentin still has surgeries ahead of
him Svetlana is doing a little bit
better
she shows me pictures of their house
before and after the attack
why did they attack us I don't know we
didn't do anything bad we're civilians
the hospital itself was not spared
either but the heart of the trauma
center here tells us after a Russian
strike his team struggled to keep going
we worked without water and electricity
we put headlamps on and took care of
those seeking medical assistants it was
very hard but we stayed here and did
what was necessary
and the situation worsened when Russian
forces completely encircled the city
residents tell us
Journey if endured weeks of Russian
Siege and just barely came through water
and electricity were almost completely
cut off no Aid could come in local
officials say at times the city buried
up to 100 people in a single day
some of them were killed by Russian
troops others died because they could
not reach the hospital due to heavy
shelling in the local morgue Edward
slepco is using refrigerator trucks for
the bodies that still needs to be
identified or pick up by relatives
many people left the country to escape
the fighting they are not in Ukraine and
cannot get back to bury their relatives
that's why there are still many bodies
here
those who come here to claim their loved
ones are overwhelmed by grief like
Igor's family he was a husband a father
a brother shot dead by Russian soldiers
he was the best brother you could have I
was so proud of him and now something
this terrible has happened to us
deaths and destruction is all that is
left after the withdrawal of Russian
forces from germanyhif and what those
who survived fear most is that the
Russian army might return
Alexandra given the atrocities that were
committed in areas Under Siege by the
Russians is the Ukrainian government
still willing to negotiate with Moscow
on ending this war
yes they
and the Ukrainian president has made it
clear repeatedly how hard it is to think
about rasumik the talks to think about
sitting together with Russian
Representatives after what happened in
butcher borodianca other places however
he also said that it's important to talk
because what the country needs is of
course a ceasefire and everyone here
wants the war to end
Alexandra thank you very much for your
reporting our correspondent Alexander
phenomen there in Kiev